welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin our last half-hour
with an offer to step back in time they
do an incredible response around the
world East Brother Island San Francisco
Bay is home to a victorian-era
lighthouse ships still rely on it and
tourists visit in droves but only two
people will get to call it their home
John Blackstone has their story on San
Francisco Bay an isolated island
seemingly frozen in the 1870s presented
an unusual job opportunity living and
working in a Victorian lighthouse
thousands found it irresistible you name
a country you know Russia China Cambodia
Vietnam but I'm telling you I can't
think of a country in the world we
didn't get applications from there was
some hurt tom but was in charge of
recruiting two people to replace Jillian
Meeker and Chae Rodgers who've been
working at the East Brother light
station for the past two years there's
not technically an address we live on a
rock they were shocked so many people
wanted the job within an hour of that
article being put out online we were
getting phone calls every five minutes
our website crashed I think three times
I think this really epitomizes that for
people that you know living in this
Victorian lighthouse on a small island
in the middle of a Bay there is a huge
desire to step back from the pace of
modern life but the pace of life on the
island isn't exactly laid-back
cook and server and dishwasher and
housekeeper and you know concierge the
East Brother light station is one of the
country's more unusual bed and breakfast
inns Jillian and Shay do everything from
running the boat that brings guests to
the island to cooking and serving meals
this is very fun most of our day
in the kitchen but not bad looking at
the window here a view of San Francisco
the five Victorian era bedrooms offer
dramatic views of waves and wildlife on
San Francisco Bay this lighthouse is now
considered a treasure but at one time
the Coast Guard was ready to demolish it
until lighthouse lovers stepped in to
save it the light itself was automated
by the Coast Guard years ago but now
it's a favorite location for Island
visitors I guess can come up here
whenever they want all the proposals
happen up here the visitors this day are
Tyler water soon in Tiffany dance the
couple selected from more than a
thousand applicants to run the place
people always ask are you going to have
a cook is a maintenance person or
anything and it's all us
you're gonna be living in the eighteen
seventies which I'm okay with
I do enjoy like suffrage and like
women's right other than that I think
I'll be quite fine among their new
duties learning to get the old foghorn
up and running
as a noisy demonstration for overnight
guests they learn as well none of all
the impressive views here no guest wants
to miss the sunset now we're gonna have
to take a break before dessert in the
summer time to go see the sunset we
found that out very very quickly while
the job is more innkeeper than
lighthouse keeper two years on the
island taught Gillian and che why so
many people wanted to work in a
lighthouse I think there's something
very symbolic about being the person
whose job it is to keep everyone safe
and being isolated in that way but also
serving such a strong purpose for CBS
this morning Saturday John Blackstone on
East Brother Island Wow those views I
know and howdy guess did they say could
stay there I'm not sure what I'd like to
be a guest I don't think I want to be
the end keeper I see a show trip coming